hey tammy hello
so what kind of dudes are you attracted
to
me um i would say dominant alpha males
that's not usually what's attracted to
me but
that is typically what i am attracted to
and would like to date or go out with
and find um
i'm not on social media but i have tried
online dating and that's been
not successful
what happens when you use online dating
i mean like are you able to match with
the guys that you're attracted to
uh some sometimes but not often there's
been a couple times where a lot of times
they will seem a certain way until you
actually get out in public with them or
get to know them a little bit more
um
and
i think also a large problem is a lot of
men
might think that they're dominant or
alpha and they're not or they might
present themselves that way but they're
still living with their mom at 43
another one that i dated had lived in a
sober house living which i think is
awesome for him but he's obviously not
ready to date but he didn't tell me that
until date five
so what is what is silver house living i
don't know what that's a sober home
living oh sober home okay so yeah so
he's an alcoholic
alcoholic or addict that's great i'm
proud of him however i don't want to
date him
um
so do you have any kids you ever been
married
i have never been married i do have two
children from when i was young they are
19 and 23 they are live in the city on
their own in college one for nursing run
one undergraduate for psychology so
they are super smart but very
independent and um
you know not home in my life all the
time but we're still very close
okay so what's the ask here i mean
you're just looking for clarity on why i
mean you're looking for some some help
some advice
probably a little all of the above uh i
i'm not sure
i take myself off of online dating i did
it for about a year and a half i'm
thinking about jumping back into it but
i'm not sure if maybe i'm using wording
wrong or presenting myself wrong and
i've really tried like i go to the gym
and i smile and i'm nice and i get
comments from people
men that i'm attracted to tend to treat
me like their little sister
the last person i dated called me
accommodating i don't know if that is a
good thing um you know that i'm i'm
helpful or nice or everyone goes oh
tammy's so sweet but it's like a friend
zone sort of thing that women do to guys
yeah but they do
that's what i end up in so yeah
me is like this sweet sweet little tammy
so are they
overtly stating it's because of the
tattoos
no
um and i wasn't i mean like when you say
tattoos all over your body like you
attach some pictures i'm not going to
show them on the screen but it looks
like it's from like neck pretty much all
the way down right
that's correct yeah okay not everything
is tattooed but i have a lot
done okay and it's like front and back
everything right yes okay
um
like have you looked into trying to get
them removed or is that like utterly
pointless so much work um i did remove i
had some tattoo work on my face like on
the top of my forehead um area i did get
that removed it took two years and over
two thousand dollars and it's still not
complete it's still blotchy how much did
you pay for all the tattoos over the
time you had your body inked i don't
really know and it was a long time ago
in my early 20s probably too much a lot
of it we would do with like trade um i
had a friend that i used to own a hair
salon a long time ago and so we prayed
between that um
and
they were
the tattoos in that time i got a lot of
attention for but because i wasn't
raised very properly i didn't understand
the difference between good attention
and bad attention
so
and i was just very young and made poor
choices but
once i started
listening to your podcast and several
others i kind of realized that that was
my i think that was something that was
kind of holding me back a lot from being
able to date is because
you know people just
a lot of men just don't want to date
somebody that's so heavily tattooed and
it'd be impossible
and they've overtly stated that like
they just said that i'm not into tattoos
um no i i mean a couple of them have but
i'm just kind of
i'm kind of guessing that um
and it's kind of out of actions like i
wouldn't have a problem necessarily
finding somebody
to take me out and want to be with me
like intimately i don't think that is
what i would have a problem with but
nobody wants to like take me to parties
or take me to a charity event or take me
home to meet their mom or
and i just think after listening to a
lot of people and kind of trying to
figure out what men are looking for and
want and what they desire in a woman
um i'm
kind of making the assumption that
that's a big thing that's holding me
back
yeah um short of getting them all
removed
you're kind of in a tough spot i mean i
mean like the thing that see
the problem a lot of women face is
they'll get to your age and they'll say
okay you know i just want a nice guy i
just want to i mean like what did you
define it as uh the guys at your chest
because the way i'm not attracting the
type of men that i'm attracted to and
you're defining the guys that you're
attracted to as like the high value
alpha guys like what's a high value
alpha guy in your view like could you
kind of paint a picture yeah and i'm i'm
very realistic so you know i i know
you know it's not i'm not going to be
pulling somebody that's you know a
millionaire i understand that uh but
somebody that just has a steady job
somebody that has a decent job making
how much money roughly
um i mean i would really prefer over 60
a year
um
oh i would like that's not a very high
bar though i know a lot of women
nowadays are like oh he's got to have
you know six-figure income
yeah i just i don't think i could be
with somebody that makes less than me um
i think that would be a problem burgundy
101 it's just i i worked i work really
hard and so i just want somebody else
that also works really hard at whatever
it is that they're doing or um and
whether and just in life in general you
know and it's hard to find somebody
that's like that that's willing to just
put in work whether it's go to the gym
or explore a hobby or if there's
something they're interested in not just
talking about it but actually going and
doing it um
and
and it's hard because i have i've worked
so hard even though i
i wouldn't call myself like the high
value woman i guess but i've worked so
hard to get where i am at that i would
really like to be with somebody that
could at least equal that if not better
um yeah women don't want to go across
and down they want to go across and up
generally speaking so i mean
what you're running into i'm assuming
you're dating you're dating guys your
age or older
um yes i i have dated a 33 year old and
that was actually oddly probably the
better one
really great guy owns his own home
motorcycle boat truck
in the petroleum business and we
actually really enjoy one another's
company and i think he likes me and i
like him however he's been very
respectfully honest with me that he
wants to get married and have kids um
several kids and so he would ideally
really prefer a younger woman so in that
case it wasn't the tattoos that were
holding me back it was the fact that i
was 40 and he doesn't want to date a
barren 40 year old um and so and he
could absolutely have a 25 year old girl
so
are you finding that with the guys your
age two that are in their 40s like
they're looking for younger women um it
depends it depends um who they are so i
have found that a little bit in men
um
usually i guess what you would classify
as your more high value man they'll date
me they don't really want to long
long-term dating they do want
you know younger women
i kind of have a hard time just finding
people to even just date
so
well like once you start going through
the dating pool and you realize about
half of it or more is going to lean in a
direction that you're not attracted to
the guys that you defined as carrying
crystals in their pockets with loads of
debt with an art history degree so you
cut those guys out of the equation then
you take the guys out of the equation
that have you know they're the
they're in the sober homes the
alcoholics anonymous they're living with
their moms they don't make more than
more money than you they still live with
their ex-wives trying to sort through
the divorce they've got four small
children and you don't want to deal with
that like you're
you're dealing with a very very very
very narrow dating pool right so for you
to kind of like find something that's
going to tick off some boxes you're
going to have to cast a wider net and
start to make some concessions in areas
that you've been unwilling to in the
past perhaps if you know what i'm saying
right because i mean like most guys that
i deal with in the high net worth
category like the guys are the
entrepreneurs the professionals the
doctors and lawyers that are making like
quarter million
plus for the most part they're not
looking for women in their 40s let alone
a woman in their 40s that's a single mom
with a couple i mean your kids are
almost adults now but you're still a
single mom basically um you know covered
in head to toe with tattoos and one of
the things that you've experienced i
mean if you have to go to an event and
there's an evening dress it's like okay
do i want to bring
you know plate one or plate two plate
two's got tats all over her and plate
one doesn't you know sort of thing so
i mean there's certain things that you
can do and you know i always tell guys
you know like try to try to max out your
looks where you can like if you're fat
lose the weight you know if you've got
you know
social calibration issues work on that
you don't seem to have that issue you're
well written you seem to speak quite
well it sounds like you don't have you
know um much going on that's problematic
as far as red flags except for the whole
tattoo thing which is gonna you know
send a lot of guys off
i don't know i mean
cast a wider net would be my biggest you
know piece of advice and if you have the
time and money you know maybe maybe work
towards getting
getting
rid of or minimizing a lot of the
exposed stuff
i'm like for me personally you're gonna
get a skewed opinion because i'm not a
big fan of tattoos right never have been
never never will be you know the way
that i've always framed it and i think i
mentioned my book i don't know if you
read it but it's like putting
bumper stickers all over lamborghini
lamborghini is a beautiful thing i think
a woman's a beautiful thing and then
when you put them all over the place and
i've got cousins that have tats you know
down their arms and sort of stuff and
they fade after 20 years they just don't
look good right so i've never been a big
fan from that perspective and i think
there's a good chunk of the guys that
share that same and echo that same
settlement but there's also guys that
love tats like i've seen guys covered in
tats as well and
i'm sure there's got to be some of them
out there that aren't drowning in debt
with crystals in their pockets that
probably have some money in a motorcycle
and a boat as well too right i would
hope so oh it just seems like that's
kind of
that does seem to be
kind of i would say
musicians
people that do a lot of drugs and
alcohol um
maybe try to find those reformed guys
that aren't these are the people that
tend to when i'm on dating apps that
will reach out to me
um
and want to talk to me
and that's fine they could live their
life the way they'd like but um it's
just not somebody i'd put time and
energy into cast a little bit of a
broader net and you know give give a few
of these guys at least a sniff test and
a a coffee date or a drink and see how
it goes and see if there's anything that
sparks out of that but i mean if you're
gonna limit it very tight one of the
things you said early on too is you're
not really dating that much i mean if
you want to score goals you got to get
on the ice right put on the equipment
put on the gear
you know i did join like that's why i
joined the gym six months ago so i
joined the gym six months ago i've been
trying to volunteer outside of my
regular job so my regular job is just
all women it's almost all women that
work there um
so
if we have men they're married um
so i tried to start doing other
volunteer things and go on like little
like 5k runs and stuff with other
people and try to be more active and so
i'll find things purposely to try and go
do
that men will be at um so i tried that
as well go and go and fish where the
fish are
they may not be you know they may not
have the right bait on the hook for you
though right
that's why i said castle wide or not and
get out there a little bit more hey
listen i appreciate you you know sharing
this experience and if anything you know
i've i've worn for a long time you know
to
younger women not to not to tap
themselves up too crazily
and you know here we are today you know
you're you're 20 years down the road and
you're like you know saying yourself
like where do i find guys that i want to
be with because i'm stuck with guys that
i'm generally not attracted to so
you know
part of this is there's a lesson here
yeah not just with men with career
opportunities with it's a huge regret if
i had a magic wand and could just take
it all off and have my freckly redhead
skin back i would so
um yeah i would definitely if you're a
younger woman watching this not get
tattooed
all right good luck tammy thank you
bye-bye thanks see ya
you